[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brady quinn co-host of two pros and a
cup of joe alongside lavar arrington and
jonas knox and you can uh catch him
weekdays 6 to 9 a.m eastern the show
that precedes hours also the big noon
kickoff on fox
in texas it'll be oklahoma at number 13
baylor brady thanks for joining us let
me start with um what you saw last night
did the dolphins provide a blueprint we
love to do this a blue
print on how to shut down lamar jackson
um i'm not willing to go that far um i i
think what we what we witnessed though
and i think one of the things that we've
noticed if you've paid attention to the
baltimore ravens
in the second half of seasons with lamar
jackson and greg roman calling plays is
i don't know if it's a matter of teams
figuring them out
but it always seems like that offense
hits a wall in the second half of the
season they usually get off to some
pretty fast starts and then they start
to kind of fizzle out and i don't know
if that's like a greg roman thing when
you comb back through the years and feel
like from some of the different teams
he's been to like they haven't had a
second act or they haven't been able to
adjust but clearly last night was one of
those examples of uh miami felt really
comfortable playing a variation of
coverages kind of some off man coverage
mixing in some zone but putting pressure
on lamar and the raven's offense lamar
did not handle it well and it also seems
like when he gets in situations
where he starts to press where i mean
he's literally feeling the pressure but
i just think also because of that point
in the game where they needed to come
back they had to do something
i feel like he almost puts himself in
some compromising situations forces
throws makes some bad decisions i think
we've seen that from him from time to
time
um but so i don't know if it's a
blueprint necessarily more so is it's
just kind of been what we've seen from
the ravens offensively speaking at least
uh since lamar jackson has been
quarterback in the second half of the
season and we're starting to venture
into that territory
and i'm also wondering about the
decision jacoby brissette gets banged up
goes out tua is the emergency
uh backup
but then he goes in he's healthy enough
to play but he wasn't healthy enough to
start i i i'm confused with uh that
whole situation brady
i joined the club yeah i've been
confused now for two years with brian
flores and the decisions
with two in particular i mean last year
when he'd yank him out
at the end of the game or at a you know
after a bad first half i mean this is
the guy you drafted in the top ten the
first round pick you've got to see what
he can do to finish games or end games i
would say this last year about him and
yet they just put ryan fitzpatrick in
and let him be the closer and i
understand that brian flores wants to
win games and he wants to do what's best
for his team to win games but then
shouldn't fitzpatrick have been starting
the whole time like it it just never
really made any sense to me
with when they chose to make the switch
to tua last year when fitz and the team
was playing well and then the times they
would take two out of the game it's like
well you already made that decision to
put him in
like don't you want to see what you have
in him don't you want to let this pay
dividends in the future where either he
brings your team back or he doesn't but
he at least learns from it
and then and this year like i mean it
was it was that case of it last week he
was dressed for it i'm going wait a
second like he's healthy enough to go in
an emergency situation but not the start
and then he goes in and he plays better
than jacoby did once he got into the
game so it's
i honestly feel like it's this if the
dolphins end up moving on from brian
flores at some point in the future
whether this season goes into a tailspin
or they don't end up achieving what they
you know hope to in the future
this will be to me at least at the top
of my list for reasons as to why because
i think he's botched
this entire situation with even seeing
what they have in two as a quarterback
and you already know everybody knows tua
knows everybody in the building knows
that they flirted with deshawn watson
and what they were willing to give up
for desean watson and almost made that
trick like i don't know what that would
be like if you knew your your wife was
negotiating with somebody else that
maybe she would leave you for that
person but then it fell through like how
would you feel showing up every day
going hi honey how are you i mean
right
no it wasn't flirting they weren't speed
dating like they they they essentially
went speed dates right they swiped right
yeah they swiped like that's like your
wife going out to one of those speed
dating things we used to have pre-coded
and you're like oh hey babe how was your
night what'd you do oh i don't know i
met 10 eligible bachelors who i was like
potentially talking to
i found one that i really liked but we
didn't really have much time you know
you only get five minutes per
conversation then you got to rotate it
was like yeah it was one of those
bizarre things when you you just made
this decision to draft him and and i
always just say this like i think
the league always lacks patience fan
bases even have even less
but with quarterbacks understanding that
like it's the one percent position that
you need time you need experience uh to
develop and and i don't know that two
has had that time
an opportunity to truly develop and i
don't know that the organization can
have a true picture of what he is or
what he isn't you know if they wanted a
guy who was more more of a a product
that was ready to go right away
they should just try to go find a
veteran quarterback they could go get or
trade for with that pick in the draft
instead of drafting a guy that's a
rookie like all these quarterbacks
coming out of the draft need work they
need some seasoning so i never really
understand that when they just want to
move on from that decision right away
look deshawn watson's an extreme talent
any team that has interest in it as a
football player obviously has to do
their due diligence if he's on the
market but there's still a lot to be
figured out off the field
and also by the way i don't think this
is done like i think in the offseason
whatever was on the table will probably
still be on the table just depends on
the legal situation that he's in if i
told you back in august these are some
of the headlines that would emerge in
the nfl cam newton would be back with
the panthers odell beckham would be a
ram
jets fans would be excited about a young
quarterback named mike white
john gruden would no longer be coaching
the raiders jordan love would start a
game but it wouldn't be due to an aaron
rodgers injury and the chiefs would be
in last place in the afc west
where would you start where you go i i
wouldn't believe that headline
the chiefs would be the last nips
i'll be honest with you everything you
threw at me i mean
well i mean let's look at the i mean
obviously the situation with john gruden
the raiders is terrible it's despicable
um but i do feel like there is a sense
for with the direction that team was
going from a win losses perspective
that at some point someone's got to kind
of you know hold them accountable
clearly that's not why he's not there
anymore but you know and even with odell
beckham there's kind of always been that
like is he happy in cleveland potential
trade rumors uh how this is going to
work out the fact that he got released
and cut uh is a different way of getting
to that um you know cam and his and his
journey back to carolina first off i'm
happy for him i'm glad he got paid got
the contract he got paid i mean i'm
gonna be honest with you i thought what
were they negotiating against brady
well no that that's that's a good
question i don't know if it was anyone
but but look but that's that's the
situation that they were in
it's like they don't have to negotiate
anyone but they're negotiating with
essentially pj walker for that period of
time right now where they're still not
technically out of the playoff on the
nfc like outside of like about five or
six teams in the nfc like that last wild
card spot the last two it's kind of wide
open
so they might feel like hey defensively
we've got a good team we could still
stay in this thing we just need a
quarterback to guide the ship there and
and cam's our best option and so it's
yeah they didn't they weren't
negotiating versus anyone else but they
were negotiating versus staring down the
rest of the season of not being
potentially in the playoff fund i mean
that's what they're negotiating against
okay so you get rid of cam then you
bring in his replacement and then you
pay teddy bridgewater 35 million dollars
then you get rid of him then you trade
for sam darnold you bring him in you
guarantee next year's contract of 19
million dollars you pass on justin
fields so now you're bringing in
cam you brought in cam's replacement
then the replacement to cam's
replacement to now
another replacement for cam's
replacement now you bring in cam to
replace cam
god i want to be cam's replacement so
bad because they all get paid right like
is that the moral of the story right now
i mean think about how much david tepper
uh and right now is paying out in
carolina because teddy bridgewater's not
even there he's still getting paid you
know you bring in sam darnold and pj
walker and it just all comes full circle
are you the same age as matt barkley
because they brought in matt barkley to
uh to play he's he's younger than i okay
yeah
he's younger than i am so trust i wish
but maybe i should just give them a call
and be like hey
services are still out there if you want
to shell out a little extra money too
while you're paying everyone
i'd love to sign up for that when's the
last time somebody reached out to you
about playing
uh it would have been back when i was i
think of 2014. i would have been back
when i was oh yeah i mean at that point
i was transitioning to broadcasting but
there was still kind of some interest
and
honestly i think once i was presented
with the opportunity i was at fox
and then when you kind of talked to some
of the teams and their interest was they
were interested but nothing where it was
anything significant and i don't want to
just go into a training camp be a camp
arm
i felt like what fox was opera you know
offering me at that time to do
was intriguing it was a great
opportunity something that like
i didn't necessarily realize how special
was that at the time of what it would
build into
um but clearly you know it was something
that i respected enough to say i'm gonna
jump into this next career and take this
opportunity who's the best quarterback
on the uh
fox set
i mean i would say me i mean look i got
that like i think every quarterback has
that mike white to them where mike
white's come out to the public like i
felt like i should have been the first
quarterback first player taking the
draft like every quarterback feels that
way about their plan about themselves
otherwise they wouldn't have played at
the nfl level or wouldn't have the
ability to like even if you like i i
think sometimes what impresses me the
most is the guys who are so
overly confident and they think they can
make every throw and they think they can
make every play
but like objectively speaking you're
looking at them going
he definitely can't do that but like
those are the guys that tend to succeed
at moments because they believe in their
abilities even when everyone else
doesn't um and that's that's why like
you know whether it's me or anyone else
mike white in this case that's why
they're such good stories is because the
journey to get there is a lonely journey
and he's probably the only one even his
parents have probably at some point in
time not believed that he was going to
be able to do in his one start and
change what he's done so far he's brady
quinn fox sports college and nfl studio
and game analyst um how does this not
work out with odell and the rams
it's a tough question to answer because
i i think it's going to work out i mean
everything the stars have aligned for it
to work out he's with a great play
caller
he's with a quarterback who you know
they're going to distribute the football
and get him the football you know you
could complain about what if he doesn't
get enough targets or touches and he
might not in comparison to cooper cup
for example i think he'll be competitive
as far as targets with robert woods
um
but odell strikes me as the type of
person i think we all have these people
like that we work with or in our lives
when they come into work like
whatever is going on in their personal
life some people can compartmentalize
and not bring that to work
other people can
like odell strikes me as the type of
person that has a hard time if he's not
happy outside of football
being able to come in and be in that
work environment and be the type of guy
that's enjoyable to be around and i also
don't think he's going to excel if
that's the case look he's got a house in
l.a he's got interest outside of
football i just think the way sean mcvay
handles that team
and how he'll fit into that team
is a perfect scenario for him so i don't
think it goes bad like i think he found
himself into the perfect situation for
him to resurrect things in his career
how does matthew stafford approach this
relationship
uh it's one in which i think look you
you get them on board you're happy to
have them
but i think he knows and obviously came
to the cleveland browns the situation
where they were in the playoff line uh
obviously the rams are squarely in the
playoff on divisional hunt so you know
you're just trying to get them up to
speed like if if anything if they don't
have a prior relationship you're just
trying to get another person you know
what motivates him what makes him tick
what he likes what he doesn't like how
he sees the game you know all those
things because you've got to get up to
speed and build that chemistry
in a short amount of time but you know
he's going to want his touches brady
because that's that's how you get the
next contract he doesn't get a contract
by being just a good team player
he gets a contract by let me show the
world what i can still do
and if you get a contract too
you get a contract too when you win
you know that if this if this carries on
to winning a super bowl
every everyone looks better when you win
a super bowl whether you're as good as
you think or not you're a world champ
yeah so as much as he wants his touches
and targets which he was still the most
targeted player
for the browns and we tend to forget
that he was still the most targeted
player just didn't quite work out so
he'll get his targets he'll get his
touches but i think if you're preaching
him on success
and then being able to go and win a
super bowl and back to my initial point
like in order to get him those touches
you still have to know the person and
player and so you still have to
understand like his nonverbal
communication how he moves how he how he
gets open how he sees his own coverages
what he likes what he doesn't like like
you still have to get all that down in
order to get him those touches so it's
it's honestly a lot of trying to hang
around
each other as much as you possibly can
if you're a mat staff or nodel beckham
like you're trying to become best
friends or speed dating if you will
using that analogy again like as fast as
humanly possible fox big noon kickoff in
waco texas it's number 13 baylor number
eight oklahoma how big is this game for
oklahoma
it's huge because this is now their case
for building their resume to get within
the top four you know they're that you
know undefeated team that's kind of
probably probably feel disrespected
and and yet since caleb williams has
taken over as their quarterback the
freshman quarterback this offense has
been unstoppable now defensively they've
suffered some injuries and they
struggled at times but this is the case
now for oklahoma to make that run
they've got to beat baylor they'll
eventually have to beat oklahoma state
and then win
presumably versus probably oklahoma
state again in the big 12 championship
game to get that resume where they
needed to to be undefeated and be a part
of the conversation to play for a
national championship
safe travels always great to talk to you
thank you have a great weekend brady
thanks for having me guys that's brady
quinn uh you can catch him two pros and
a cup of joe alongside lavar arrington
jonas knox that's fox sports radio
weekday 6 to 9 a.m eastern that precedes
our show and